[Musique]
vous l'avez reconnu et où c'est bien
nous karl lagerfeld timide et un peu
stressé le jeune couturier présentait sa
création concours du secrétariat
international de la laine en janvier
1955 il finira première ex-aequo avec un
certain yves saint laurent aujourd'hui
lagerfeld fait partie des grands noms de
la haute couture
mais dès le début de sa carrière le
styliste allemand mettait un point
d'honneur à habiller aussi monsieur et
madame tout le monde
des vêtements pour femmes pour rome pour
enfants et aussi des sous vêtements qui
pour moi sont des vêtements tout court
et je trouve que le petit monde sous est
presque péjoratif car je trouve que dans
des sous-vêtements va être aussi à
l'aise que dans les autres et bêtement à
cette époque lagerfeld mène une carrière
de styliste indépendants ils travaillent
dans le monde entier pour une vingtaine
de maisons différentes
fendi chloé mais aussi des marques de
prêt-à-porter en général je ne fais
jamais pu faire la même chose à venir je
fais une collection de robes cher tu me
rejoindre à bon marché des pull-overs
les maillots de bain mais je n'étais
jamais même dans l'autre pays
but faire la même chose une polyvalence
qui contribuent au succès du couturier
et qui plaît aux marques pour cette
fabricante de vêtements karl était
surtout un grand visionnaire qu'il
regarde également dans les détails un
talent qui le mènera jusqu'à la maison
chanel en 1983
lagerfeld est nommé directeur artistique
de la marque en parallèle il lance sa
propre griffe de prêt-à-porter à son nom
car pour le créateur
le style n'est pas une question de prix
ceux qui ont envie et les moyens navals
et les robes fait sur l bon d'accord
mais ça n'est plus indispensable pour
être bien habillé aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui en bêta billet très bien
avec pas beaucoup d'argent du tour est
une question de goût de choix de style
personnel au fait cette philosophie
accompagnera karl lagerfeld tout au long
de sa carrière en 2004 il est le premier
styliste a collaboré avec la marque de
prêt-à-porter suédoise haché
[Musique]